let's jump to this story from the post
millennial which is currently loading
here we go resurfaced footage shows
United CEO performing Lady Gaga drag
routine at company Halloween party okay
for a variety of reasons uh I am going
to hereby announce where possible
timcast will no longer use United for
any of
itel I mean it so we book uh I think we
have 1.5 flights per day for this show
uh and so why the reason it's 1.5 is
that guest flies in same day guest flies
out so that actually it it I think we
might be be doing two per day two two
flights per day not 1.5 two per day and
uh one or two on the weekends and then
pop culture crisis has a guest on the
weekends we don't book flights for every
single guest some people come from DC
it's one of the reasons we chose to be
in the area because a lot of uh higher
profile political commentators are are
local yeah some people live in like
Philly can drive down it's only a couple
hours so there's a wide range of areas
that we're in but typically we're flying
people out every day and uh I have
already instructed the staff I said is
it possible for us to completely ditch
United Airlines and we believe it is I
want to be careful on how I describe
this because when you're dealing with
something as big as an airline when
there's actually very few it may not be
possible in some circumstances to say we
won't use United that's why I say we're
possible however pretty sure American
Airlines uh operates in in in all the
exact same areas that being said the
challenge with any kind of boycott is
that you know American Airlines Delta
and all these brands are doing the exact
same garbage the issue here is that the
CEO himself has advocated for illegal
activities that's right ill committing
crimes the CEO of United has advocated
for hiring on the basis of race which is
a violation of the 1964 Civil Rights Act
that's illegal and so long as this compy
has a guy doing a drag Lady Gaga routine
where he celebrates breaking the law and
being racist we are not going to utilize
their Airline now I know I know in 10
seconds someone's going to point at
American Airlines they're say look at
all these bad things they're doing and
to which I say okay Spirit Airlines it
is uh you know but I I don't know our
guests are like we don't want to go
anymore we'll pay for our own travel
it's funny I was looking at the United
thing and I said this morning I even
tweeted I said I don't really feel that
safe no more being on their planes after
saying that it's a rough kind of wacky
it is isn't it I mean like I'm very
nervous all female like black flight
crew is like man that that just don't
look right man it's it's not right I
want a man at the front of it honestly I
don't care do I want the doors to stay
on the plane crazy it'll sound racist
and it'll sound kind of coonish but
honestly I'm safer feeling if it there's
a white man flying my plane only because
every time I've flown it's been a white
pilot I like what I'm used to it's what
I'm used to the issue here is these
diversity higher
practices make people they exacerbate
racism yeah because if you say we are
going to hire lower on the on the ladder
to be diverse the Assumption then is the
pilot you have who's not white must be
not as skilled and that's that's not
fair could you imagine being like the
best pilot in the world and you're black
but everyone's like yeah he's probably
not that good I'll be like come on man
like I worked my ass off for this and
then these far- leftists come in and
start making the claim that everyone's
got a higher lower down on the on the
talent pool they're making the problem
worse yeah there was a Gallup poll that
said 52% of black Americans oppose
affirmative action and they're they like
the affirmative action ban that the
Supreme cour I I I hate Democrats man
yeah Democrats talk to black people the
Yale study remember this one yes they
talk down to people they talk down to
black people but but talk talk down is
that like the right way to phrase it
they dumb down their language and act
stupid when they're talking to black
people yeah
conditioned they've conditioned us to
think that way and speak that way they
they've made out our language that that
dumb down slang type language that
simpler type terms the non-political
verbiage really like when they were
pushing ebonics yeah look at look at
this this is from 2018 white liberals
dumb themselves down when they speak to
black people and new study Contents I
despise these people so much D I mean I
think that's definitely true just having
been in Lefty circles for my entire life
that I think that's definitely true I
had a friend tell me that she preferred
the racism of the South to the racism of
the North she was like at least in the
South you know that they're racist they
say that they're racist then they treat
you normally in the north they say
they're not racist and then they're
racist at you okay but then the
Scientific American ran this article
this year saying uh black children who
speak African-American English are
routinely misdiagnosed with speech
disorders so they're saying like
everyone's misdiagnosed with disorders
these days of course but also there's
this level of like this institution
which because we know educators are
predominantly left left leaning they're
saying you're supposed to act this way
culturally but also we're misdiagnosing
you I mean this is like the most
conflicting information to give
especially young children the way you
speak is okay sometimes but also in
school except maybe we think it's wrong
and they complain about code switching
yeah it's like it's all mixed
messages yeah thought that was a crazy
headline when I went to Sweden I said it
was one of the most racist places I've
ever been to oh wow and everyone was
shocked but they're all Lefty and
they're like Progressive and I'm like
uh-huh yeah and they they put all their
migrants into enclaves where they
separate them brag about how not racist
they are and then don't hire them I'm
like it's it's it is this air of I'm
such a better person I'm not racist and
then when it actually comes down to
practice they're like oh no get away
from me yeah that's what we see with
white liberals in the United States even
but uh going back to you know United
here's here's the video we'll uh we
we'll play it for you I know you guys
don't want to watch it but you're going
to have
to so uh
okay how would you respect someone who
like if this was your boss and this is
what you looking at now this was a
Halloween part this was like a Halloween
thing but it was still a company
Halloween thing okay I gotta be honest I
I really don't care that the dude is
doing Lady Gaga drag stuff I it's like
it's like whatever man I guess uh I
think Lady Gaga makes great pop music
more power to her if this guy you know
gets his rocks off by dressing like a
woman and dancing around in front of his
employees hey I'm libertarian just keep
the kids out of it the issue is that
he's on in an interview with axio
bragging about how he intends to break
the law he's sitting there being like
I'm a criminal and a racist at the same
time and I want to cause harm to this
I'm like dude screw you this is just
like okay I I said this I I personally
boycotted United long before we knew the
CEO with some weirdo you know what I
mean some some racist well cuz United is
not good I have flight credits with them
and I'm using them up and then we're
done I don't fly don't fly United man
I'll tell you we were flying back from I
think it was uh I can't remember where
we were we were in California I think it
was when when I went to Tijana for the
uh medical stuff and then on the way
back over the weekend we stopped in
Vegas that's what happened when we were
flying back from Vegas United at 3 in
the morning switched my plane ticket to
a different plane without telling me so
when I shut to the airport my ticket
wasn't working I had to get ticket and
then they put me from first class a
ticket I bought and they put me into the
back into the um basic economy seats
that's crazy and they still charge you
for first class as far as I know I never
got I I I did I I attempted to charge
back saying I did not buy these tickets
I want a refund I want my money back I
don't know what happened with it to be I
think we got I think I got a refund I'm
not sure I'm not sure but I think I did
but I'm sitting here thinking like how
is it that I paid all this money and now
all of a sudden the charger stole my
credit card I'm on a a totally different
plane to a different city in a different
seat I didn't pick and my flight was
still flying out on on schedule the
issue was that the flight so it was uh
like Houston to DC and the flight I was
supposed to be on in Houston was delayed
so they took it upon themselves to move
me to without without telling me and I'm
like I could have just gone to Houston
and then opted for a for a flight there
right just because my flight was delayed
do not I was I was I was livid it insane
that they would do that they put me on a
flight from Vegas to Denver to DC that's
annoying and they do it because they're
probably thinking we don't want people
sitting in the airport if we can get
them to their destination just do it
don't ask them screw screw United do not
fly United if you do you're supporting
you know racists you don't to be racist
do you right do you Hanah clar why are
you asking me wow no I'm just kidding
but the thing is I can't take this
person seriously like I get it he can do
whatever it's not that I don't want him
to not do whatever brings him Joy it's
just like this is your boss and like I
get it's a comedy Halloween party but
like it's about choices like I don't
know like that's just if he chooses to
represent himself that way how does he
represent his airline when you're Bo
when you're bowing Max
7379 is crashing the last thing that's
going to go through your head is going
to be this
video that's horrifying I'd hate that
yeah that is horrifying I fly a lot for
work I travel a lot and uh I've been
increasingly
um wary of air travel yeah and I'm kind
of like I have can I just drive across
the country what if we just do that do
remember Co when people road trip all
all kinds of places yeah but I was
flying during Co because the airport
ports were empty the only people you
ever saw in the airports were wearing
Maga hats and you'd be like hey what's
going on oh wow it was cool there was
nobody on the flight and it was just a
bunch of conservatives and Trump
supporter flying around the country
being like it's cheap Mark Cuban's
debating people online about like
diversity and stuff but the there's
there's there's one point that Mark
cubin cannot ever refute publicly
stating your intention to hire someone
based on race is a criminal act or it's
like it's admission of guilt in and the
intention to commit a crime we have a
law in this country that's been there
for 60 years that you cannot
discriminate on the basis of race and
Mark cu's like no it's a good thing okay
well look it's really simple if you got
an issue with what Mark Cuban is saying
sue him it's about time everybody who's
sick of the diversity quota stuff starts
suing the moment any company okay so
first you need standing so if there's a
company that says we're only let's say
you guys listen you're listening okay
tell your friends this you work for a
company right they say we got a new
position or we're promoting but it's for
people of color file a lawsuit you will
win in two seconds you'll put 10 grand
in your pocket it is illegal what they
are doing you cannot do this there
there's uh uh you see this all the time
with like housing it was a big big deal
because on Craigslist there are a bunch
of women who say like no men allowed and
you cannot discriminate in housing and
it caus a lot of problems there are guys
who sue bars the bars will have ladies
night and they'll say 20 20% off all per
all drinks for women and so there's like
this old guy old gu like there's an
older guy who's in his late 50s who just
goes around the country suing These Bars
he instantly wins you know why because
the bar gets served the lawsuit and they
say what is this we're being sued for
having ladies night and their lawyer
says yeah that's illegal you should pay
them
and they'll be like he wants 10 grand
they'll be like you should pay him
because you're going to lose and it's
going to cost you more than that and
they write him a check and then they
cancel ladies night if that's been going
on for 20 years all I can think of is
John Lovitz anybody who works for United
right now should be following a lawsuit
calling a lawyer and saying the CEO on
axio said they have quotas for people of
color I feel like I am being held back
and not being given a raise because of
my race blah blah blah the company has
explicitly stated the CEO they commit
they they illegally illegally
discriminate in in the workplace sue
them women are people of color so they
just classify both of them into like
either or yeah it's just kind of dis
Civil Rights Act is written it's yeah
but that's and then now retro yeah it is
and now it's retroactively gender
identity is part of it yeah oh man so
everywhere it says protections for women
it's protections for gender identity
that makes me mad did you see the thing
where like now um You can pick
non-gender or opposite gender on your
passport on
yourport really well for you when you
fly to other countries and they arrest
you that's right and that's what they
said that's what the state department
said they were like some countries won't
honor this passport if you lie on it and
you can also lie on your child's uh
birth certificate now you can put on
exgender I'm for it I'm for it so look I
got to tell you man you're like just go
as far as you can make yourselves insane
like
looking creating a false document when
you go to the US the the purpose of a
passport is to identify you to a foreign
country they will then choose to Grant
you excess some countries have what's
called Visa upon entry a lot of them do
some of them have they don't have visa
on Entry but they basically do like I
think when I went to Egypt that you show
up you walk up to a there's a counter
and then they give you a Visa you pay
the money they stamp your passport then
you go to immigration control and that's
not visa on Entry because you had to go
to a kiosk a lot of countries you walk
right in you walk up you say I got an
American passport this
stamp thank you for your money some
countries don't do this and scroll they
they they go through your passport
identify you and you have to have
pre-approval before entering this
country if you lie on your passport and
then apply for a Visa and then show up
and the and the person at the boorder of
you know Customs or whatever for this
country says you applied for a Visa
claiming to be a man but you're a woman
or you're a woman claiming to be a woman
but you're a man denied you are a liar
you're in serious trouble
here's the other thing too it's going to
get really really interesting because
when you're trying to fly
internationally to a country that
requires a Visa the airlines will say
please you know uh check check in to
prove you have the Visa because if say
United flew you to Brazil and you did
not have a Visa guess who's responsible
for bringing you there now what happens
if you go to United and you know you're
very clearly a man but your passport
says woman and you have a Visa and the
Visa says the same thing because you
apply online you uh to get like a Visa
you go through a broker and they send in
the photos and then Brazil will approve
then you show up and they go uh you lied
you are not a woman you're a man why are
you trying to sneak into the country
it's going to be funny when United
approves you you land and then they say
United why did you allow this person to
lie on their visa and come to this
country you're responsible and then
unit's like oops it's going to be crazy
because look there's a lot of countries
that are not going to tolerate this so
you got all these right now there's not
that many people who do it like what was
it the small the low thousands of
individuals who' have actually changed
their passports but this is why I tell
people like some people even joke about
it like oh I'm going to get an x on my
ID it's funny I'm like nah you shouldn't
do that it's really dumb yeah because
then one day you're going to be like
hanging out and I don't know you're
going to you're going to go on vacation
to like Romania or something and
someone's going to look at your ID and
they're going to be like this is fake
you're under arrest yeah yeah plus I
feel like we should like like the thing
before it goes away we should be like
yes put my gender on my passport because
one day it'll be vintage and they will
just remove it entirely like it also
though speaks to what we were talking
about earlier with regard to trusting
the federal government how do you trust
a government that allows fabricated
Federal documents like that's just crazy
like oh you the the the United States
government puts out identification
documents that are rif with lies and
they approve that why would you it makes
you question anything else they put out
right any official document any official
study anything they f yes which already
we're in trouble which is like kind of
how we operate anyways dude this stuff's
so weird it's just so it's so it's
social breakdown right before our eyes
no one is asking your gender because
they're trying to insult you or your sex
nobody's saying like tell me what's in
your underwear that's the ARG to make
what do you want I I think it's really
funny because um they always try to pull
this thing where they're like Tim wants
genital inspections for for sporting
events and I was like it's called the
physical everyone gets one y like I
don't know why you're calling it a
genital EXP inection but you get a
physical you go to the doctor to make
sure you're okay what are you talking
about every Olympic athlete ever is like
Yes sounds good this is completely
normal procedure it's funny because the
left's argument is if we say males can't
compete in female sports it would
require General inspections and I'm like
dude they take their blood they like
extract the blood from these athletes
which is much more invasive also it it
it's a lie anyway because you don't need
a genital inspection to tell the
difference between a boy and a girl or a
man and a woman it's blatantly obvious
just by looking at them even from across
the room you can tell you can tell the
difference that's all made up between
men and women I don't know what you're
talking it's all pretend obvious it's
just obvious it just depends on how you
feel like that I was listening to some
uh n uh interview when I was coming in
today and they were talking about like
oh yeah I mean gender is is not real and
masculinity and femininity gender is not
real they were saying masculinity and
feminity are madeup Concepts but how can
that be possible if we see the patterns
repeated over and over again I think
this is the weird thing that all of
these conversations are trying to do
which is that your brain desires to
categorize and process information as
fast as it possibly can right and so the
idea that we have identified a
difference between males and females
that's both physical but also
psychological it presents self behaviors
like this is super normal it helps us
Advance as a society why would you want
to be like actually it all doesn't
matter actually it all means nothing
actually if you assume any of this stuff
you're bigoted and hateful and you
should question yourself like why would
you want there to be chaos unless you in
some way thrive in the chaos or profit
off it yeah or it furthers your own um
rewriting of reality and your own sense
of discontent within yourself right like
you need other people to be miserable
because you yourself are
miserable misery loves company should be
like the motto for Trans I think that is
one of the weird things that happens
though people who see people who are
like thriving and doing well want them
to suffer also the left entirely the
left entirely is misery loves company
yeah yeah it's it's it's terrifying what
a horri way to live you know like that
when when Biden I've talked about this a
couple times but when Biden did his
first speech he was saying you know
we're the party of the future and
they're the party that wants to divide
and hates you anyways I'm going to spend
this whole time fear-mongering and
telling you how this like Maga extremist
group is trying to ruin the government
and also I'm only going to talk about I
believe the shielding is what created a
misery they were shielded from
everything shielded from criticism
shielded from bullying all the stuff
well it's because of cowards yeah it's
because of cowards uh you know I I think
of it like a fire right you've got a
small fire in the in the kitchen and
when this first started you needed only
a few people who knew how and were
willing to put the fire out and deal
with it instead everyone stood around
and was just like it's not my kitchen
I'm not doing anything and so they
watched as the fire grew and grew and
grew and it got to the point until
finally it caught the attention of
people who tried to put it out and now
we're winning we're pushing back on it
if just when when all this wokeness
started the the the the people who were
working for these companies just said
shut your mouth we would never have
gotten to this point yeah and at the
time I remember CU you know like I spoke
out against trans stuff in theater in
New York and that didn't go super well
oh wow um yeah it was didn't go super
well um but no one else was willing to
speak out even my friends who all agreed
with me right but they wouldn't speak
out and you could see all over the place
people would say quietly they're making
me put my pronouns in my bio for work I
don't agree with it but they would do it
anyway and there was so much cancel
culture that people would say you know
I'm afraid to speak out and be like oh
it's too bad that you're afraid to speak
out and it's like at the time I remember
saying to people like if we just all
said the truth if we all just spoke up
we couldn't get cancelled because
there's way more of us than there are of
them we know what reality is we know
what the truth is and all we have to do
is stand up stand on the word speak up
say the truth and everyone was afraid to
do it we were all just pushed around by
like the green-haired Mean Girls with
nose piercings who were screaming at us
telling us we were bigot this silent
majority phenomena has been going on for
a long time I mean this is also true of
saying that you should you know restrict
B immigration over the border for a long
time Republicans were afraid to talk
about this Democrats at one point were
the ones calling for Border restrictions
and ultimately became this you're being
racist you're being anti-human Arian
people need this you can't talk about
this and then culture shifted and it
suddenly became something that you could
talk about I I find this well it's
because people kept talking like a bunch
of us just kept talking even though we
lost our jobs or friends or whatever and
I think it's just like nothing new Under
the Sun kind of one of those things cuz
Council culture I feel like any partty
that Embraces Council culture they only
have about eight years maximum to have
that dominance because I remember in the
past distinctively when I was younger my
mom was a republican Christian and she
was also a part of Christian Council
culture I remember it being a thing like
counceling Harry Potter canceling GTA
caning NWA that was Christian canceling
these things Andor too hated all that
and they copied what Christians really
did and magnified it you know it
intensified it to the point that we see
now but since it's intensified I say
conservatives had they grasp on America
through Council culture maybe like 12
years since it's so much stronger I
think liberals only have about six Max
kind of running out Supreme dominance
people could only take so much just like
maybe with conservatives they could only
take so much with liberals they took it
way too far too fast and we just don't
have that uh the patience for it just
it's a lot if you hit as hard as you hit
you'll leave just as fast was that
frustrating for you growing up if your
mom was the one being like you can't do
these things did you see the it wasn't
really that she was just joining the
boycotts I remember like with Harry
Potter I could never watch Harry Potter
or if she ever seen a Harry Potter book
my mom would burn a book cuz she said
she burn she hard to burn a book it's
she find way she would find a way she
would find a way she would put and did
she tell you like I'm doing this because
I believe this or were you just like my
mom's wild Christian conservative belief
she'll say that witchcraft that's a
devil uh don't fund token and I think
it's kind of funny cuz that's one of the
main person people speaking out against
transgenderism now which is crazy so it
really just shows that things come full
circle conservatives were canceling her
in the past now Liberals are canceling
her right over two different totally
different things I think sometimes
there's this especially if something's
been popular culture uh people feel like
oh well I don't want my kid to like
resent me for keeping this from them and
so they they're hesitant to say like
this is why we don't do this as a family
or like they're trying to find a way to
sort of balance I and I can understand
that it must be really difficult I don't
have kids I can't imagine a challenge
maybe Li can talk about it but that that
idea that your mom was like it's not
even that you can't read it it's so
we're going to burn it it's kind of
fascinating it's yeah they it was a lot
of Christians or at least conservatives
around my area would not engag in any of
those things they didn't call it Council
culture at the time it was called
standing on your beliefs or standing for
Christ but in a political sense it is
Council culture into my opinion
canceling GTA a video game now was
looked absurd but back then it was very
serious business thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a member
over at timcast.net